في تطورات العمليه العسكريه التركيه
الشماليه سوريا اخذت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره
ان الجيش التركي جدد استضافه لمواقع ما
تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه من خلال
قواعده المنتشره في مناطق المعارضه شمال
غرب سوريا واضافت المصادر ان القصف
التركيه طالم مواقع تلك القوه في منطقتي
شيوخ تحتاني بمحيط مدينه عين العرب في ريف
حلب وقرى صيدا وتل طويل وتل لبن والخالديه
والطريقه الدولي بريف الحسكه وفي سياق
متصل نقلت وسائل اعلام كرديه عن محمود
برخدان عضو القياده العامه لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه قوله انهم بداوا اعداد
جدول جديد لعمليات ملاحقه تنظيم الدوله
بالتنسيق والاشتراك مع التحالف الدولي
من جهتي رحب قائد ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي بالمواقف الدوليه
التي وصفها بانها رافضه للعمليه التركيه
وفي مقال نشرته صحيفه واشنطن بوست بعنوان
نحن الحليف الاكثر ولاء لامريكا في سوريا
لا تنسونا قال مظلوم عبدي انه يتمنى ان
تترجم هذه المواقف الدوليه الى خطوات
عمليه
لانهائجمات الجيش التركي كما اعرب عن امله
في ايجاد حل سياسيا عادلا لازمه السوريه
والقضيه الكرديه حسب تعبيره